everyone welcome back and let's write
some more neat code today so today let's
solve a pretty easy and popular question
invert binary search tree so all they
tell us to do
is invert a binary tree and what exactly
does that mean
so let's say that this is our initial
tree
to invert it is basically what you can
tell
in the output right so the root stayed
the same but you can see it's two
children which were left child two left
or right child seven
were swapped right so seven is now on
the other side
two has been moved right so basically we
took these
and then we swapped them and when they
say invert the binary tree it's a
recursive definition so take a look at
this
subtree right you can see since we moved
it to this side that's where it is
right but notice how even these sub
trees
are are different now right one was
initially on the left and three was
initially on the right
but now three is on the left and one is
on the right
the exact same thing happened with this
tree right it was moved
over here to the left side but then
its children were also swapped right so
nine
was moved to the left six to the right
so when they say
invert the binary tree what we're saying
is
visit every single node in the tree
right
and every time we visit a node take a
look at its
two children and swap the positions
of the children right so in other words
if we're given a
tree look at the root node and take its
children and then swap the positions and
then
recursively run inver binaries
or invert tree on the left subtree and
run invert on the right subtree so it's
a recursive definition
so we can solve this problem with
recursion we can do
a depth first search whether it's
pre-order or post
order it doesn't actually matter a depth
first search will
allow us to solve this problem
recursively so this problem would
probably be a lot more annoying
if it were iterative but luckily we can
do it recursively so
we can first check the base case so if
the root is null
then we can return null we don't have to
continue
otherwise what we're going to do is swap
the children
so we're going to save the left value
root.left in a temporary variable then
we're going to
replace the root.left value with
root.right
and then we're going to replace the
root.right value with the left value
which we know is now
stored in temp so after we swap the
nodes
all we have to do is now recursively
invert the
subtrees so we can invert the left
subtree
and then we can invert the right subtree
so by doing self.invert tree what we're
doing is making a recursive call to the
function we're inside
and once we have swapped the roots
children once we have inverted the left
subtree and
inverted the right subtree we know we're
finished so then we can return the root
so there it is this problem is a
relatively short code it's a very good
problem to kind of understand the basics
of
depth first search and tree problems in
general and it's actually a pretty
popular problem
and if you weren't able to solve this on
your first try don't feel too bad take a
look at this trivia
there was a very good engineer who
actually failed this problem in their
google interview
but his career still turned out pretty
fine so i hope this was helpful
if it was please like and subscribe it
supports the channel
a lot and i'll hopefully see you pretty
soon